in 1805 and he did the operation he did
the operation twice both of the patients
died but he realized that it was a step
in event and recommended it for all
cases requiring abdominal delivery the
mortality of the classic cesarean
section has improved as time has gone on
and it did not seem that we needed a
better method of abdominal delivery but
our ideas of what was good also improved
in 1870 the mortality of 15% in cesarean
section was not bad in 1900 the
mortality of 4% was considered excellent
in 1930 a mortality of 1% is too much
therefore when in 96 Chris Frank a bum
introduced the operation of oleanders
the low cervical incisions
it was eagerly seized by the German
operators and its use has been spread
over Europe and now in the United States
it likewise is receiving recognition the
principle of the new operation is that
the incision is made in the lower
uterine segment the neck of the uterus
and not in the funder and all the
superiority of the new operation grows
out of the effect
there are two kinds of low cervical
Saverio one where the incision being
made just above the pubis approach to
the lower uterine segment is gained by
cutting through the peritoneal cavity it
is called the intra peritoneal method
the other kind is where the incision is
made just above the pubis and the
parenting and is pushed upwards towards
the navel off of the bladder and the
bladder is pushed to the side and an
area of low uterine segments exposed
sufficiently large for the delivery of
the baby this is called the extra
peritoneal method the general peritoneal
cavity not being focused the majority of
men prefer the direct route the
intraperitoneal method the indication
for the low cervical caesarean section
are exactly the same as for the classic
bazarian section but owing to the safety
of the low operation we can extend the
field in which it may be don't now it is
a fact that in the United States too
many cesarean sections are being done
and it is also affect that it's the new
operation were generally practiced the
total number of Solarians done in the
United States would be reduced I shall
have occasion to refer to this point
later on the country invocation to the
operation are very few in a woman with a
pendulous belly it may be hard to get
access to the lower part of the abdomen
to make the incision and if you are
going to do a peril it is hardly
worthwhile to do the low operations but
if at any time you have to do the old
classic make it as low in the uterus as
possible don't forget as many of the
advantages of the low operation as are
to be had now a few words about the
surgical Anatomy
here is a model of a woman at term but
not in labor there is the cervix and
here the lower uterine segment which is
about nine centimeters long
this is variable but it nearly always is
long enough for you to expect the baby
through it here is the loose peritoneum
over the lower uterine segment and here
is the fashion this white lines the
pressure that extended from the vagina
upward and leaves it itself towards the
fundus of the uterus it is about this
point that the grey theme is located you
will hear a great deal about the green
theme during the operation
here is a model Java woman who has been
in the second stage for a long time and
you can see how long and thin the more
uterine segment and cervix are they are
fully 15 centimeters long and the lower
uterine segment almost invites you to
cut into it when you do your first low
cervical select the case where these
labor has been done for considerable
length of things and that makes it much
easier you think how thin it is
here is the peritoneum again and here is
the contraction rate now gentlemen a few
words about local anesthesia
it is particularly well adapted to the
low cervical cesarean section and I
prefer it to spinal anesthesia indeed
two general anesthetics - no one can
deny that spinal anesthesia is more
dangerous than the local infiltration
and since we can in 90% of the cases
succeed
with local infiltration anesthesia this
should be the method of choice and I
have here in my hand the instruments
that we use at the Chicago lying-in
Hospital they facilitate the operation
but ordinary syringes will do the work
just as well we use an ANOVA cane
procane solution one-half of 1% and we
add two minam's of adrenaline to every
ounce of the solution we use seven or
eight ounces sometimes nine or ten and
we have never had any cases of poisoning
or any trouble whatever after the baby
is born a quarter of a grain of morphine
and one one hundred and fiftieth of
scopolamine are given Solomon said that
you should have an understanding heart
and this will help you a great deal in
your operating under local anesthesia no
tugging no pulling no jarring of the
patient gentleness all the time and you
will succeed now gentlemen let us
proceed to the answer
do the operation now mrs. family we are
ready to start don't you have faith in
the head just a little when the baby
comes
I'll prepare you if any of my work
should give you pain stay out but don't
move
many book
helium is a very fine needle to make and
real in the skin then the big needle
doesn't hurt when it goes in
Injection lava came into the skin itself
and of course in his expression right
under the skin
inject as you move the needle in and out
can you feel that
you feel that
it's going to see the Gracie where the
loose peritoneum of the uterus becomes
friendly against being polluted is here
but I prefer the physics
on this drawing you see where the cramp
roll and how the scissors cut below
either the front under television see
how the forces are to be applied and the
head delivery please and chemical effect
of reports slowly little hurry
now mrs. Herman but baby is about to
come be brave don't worm breathe quietly
and in a very few moments you will hear
the baby cry
I am putting my finger in the baby's
mouth to bring it to the front be
careful we can injure the little mouse
wipe out the baby's mouth because it's a
staff that might suck in like Romney on
[Music]
mr. faucitt played under the lift of the
wound be very careful of that
[Music]
get lots of time very slowly and gently
all the instruments have been removed
from the wound
no big lots of time
little hurry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we want to get the baby be determined to
have a left punch and
[Applause]
namitha Thurman before the sleep you
have a fine healthy baby and also we've
had a hypothermic
gentlemen we will now proceed to the
repair of the roof in this animated
drawing which mr. Carlson made you will
see the course of the suture
avoid them your coaster
swing the needle around now in the upper
part of the uterus the muscle is much
thicker and is likely to retract up into
the body of the uterus what kind of
suture material do you use dr. Julie we
use number two catgut for the first row
the second row we use number one and for
the peritoneum number one
very important to get a good position
here in order to have a firm scar in the
lower portion of the fundus and the
cervix
don't catch the gods in the needle
pull it out a little later the
complications of the third stage very
seldom is their postpartum hemorrhage in
lateral tracheotomy especially if you
use local anesthesia and the dips are
just 15 minutes after the baby is born
and the title of pituitary right after
this first should be enrichment at
uterus but I do that as routine and if
you wanted to give pituitary as it's
genetically injected under the personal
as I put it under the curve Liam because
if the solution is infectious and makes
an abscess the abscess is not looking
into the peritoneal cavity some a
t-shirt believes that the scent of
previa is not a good indication for
natural technologies but our experience
in 30 cases without mortality to the
contrary there are three or possible
sources that must be related in the
first place in mimimic in anemic cases
precede the operation by a transfusion
at birth and second save blood
throughout the whole course of the
operation don't waste them first deliver
the baby by version extraction and
concede slowly so not to do any tears
first the first lamp fell the bleeding
vessel and hold them securely clamped
from Korea suture mountain do not fear
the difficulties that you might
encompass the field is not important and
we can meet the emergencies of their
life the hemorrhage you can control by
the ordinary through surgical methods
and mechanic
four companies are overcome by taking
time and by arts instead of strength let
me again recommend the most radical
cesarean or lateral tracheotomy as well
as local anesthesia any of the
difficulties an ordinarily skilled
surgeon can overcome and if you want to
run this operation as a new team I am
sure that you will cut your mortality in
half
what are the particular features of the
low cesarean that make it so superior as
I said before the operation these points
of superiority grow out of the fact that
the incision is in the lower uterine
things and I will now give you ten of
these points of superiority
the first point is that the incision is
in the lower part of the abdomen all the
surgeons know that the lower abdomen is
more resistant to infection than the
upper abdomen the intestine and the
omentum and rarely come into view and
are not touched
therefore shock is small and there is
less a tendency to vomiting after the
delivery and to cilia that still is
located right around the rules and has
very little distribution which also
helps prevent shock Ilyas and the nausea
and vomiting the cervix in which the
incision is made is more resistant to
infection they used to it every gene
ecologist knows how much the cervix
content I will now show you this on
another chart
[Music]
this chart has shown for delivery so the
uterus a few hours after delivery as you
see the cervix shrink and drop into the
pelvis out of the general peritoneal
cavity that was point five point six in
this chart you see the uterus a few
hours after delivery and as you will
notice the wound in the cervix has
dropped down into the cavity of the
pelvis far away from the general
peritoneal cavity that was 0.5 in the
list of superiority one of the greatest
advantages of the Lowell incision lies
in the security of the scar in
subsequent pregnancies and labor only a
few cases of rupture of the scar during
pregnancy have been put on record and
the number of ruptures of this scar
during actual labor is only a small
fraction of those that occur after the
classic cesarean section the reason for
this security from rupture is easily
filled by a reference to these charts in
this operation the rule is in the lower
uterine segment which is at rest and can
heal in peace it is not disturbed by the
turmoil going on in the fundus above
compare that room with this after the
classic cesarean section
here the wound is in the fundus which is
in a constant state of unrest the
uterine contraction the after pains keep
up a constant motion and sooner or later
one of these stitches or more the
Bellinger face will tear and let the cut
the Nokia and bacteria into the wound
and in through the peritoneal cavity
point of superiority number seven in the
old classics ethereum they'll ochio has
a chance to peek through the uterus into
the general peritoneal cavity causing
fair tonight in the new operation the
lower cervical the luckiest is prevented
from seeping truth and is confined to
the neighborhood of the cervix and under
the bladder should infection occur which
is not common see how easy it is to
drain the area that is infected either
you can fill the cervix down with a
valve selling and make an anterior
calcutta me that's reaching the abscess
under the bladder or you can borrow a
finger through the stitches into the
abscess or what is most common nature
helps you in that the touch our vows
under the bladder around the bladder
through the cavity of reaches and by
taking out one two or three of these
stitches you can let the pus out and
usually healing is very rapid and
complete
for comparison's see where the infection
would travel after a classic cesarean
section
and beginning here in the endometrium
all through the peritoneal cavity
[Applause]
adhesions are common after the classic
cesarean section and the reason is very
plain when the infection and possibly
the intestines and the omentum on the
other hand after the low operation
adhesions are very rare and you can see
why the wound has dropped down into the
pelvis far away from the general
peritoneal cavity and the omentum almost
never come down to low the intestines
hardly ever and when the bladder fills
the peritoneal line of suture that
little line of suture I showed you at
the operation drops down into a deep
coded sac and it's further protected
finally here but there are many other
reasons the classical cesarean section
is only faith while it is an operation
of election we can give a woman a good
test of labor and then perform a low
cervical severe e infection and
therefore by giving them a tested labor
a great many to Varian's will be
unnecessary and thus the total
percentage in the United States will be
reduced now gentlemen in conclusion I
have here the mortality statistics of
the United States Census Bureau in
Washington and from these tables we can
learn that over 500 women die from
severe infections every year this is an
enormous number and bring the talents a
opprobrium of the community when our
statistics of maternal mortality are
compared with those of other nations
it's not real treacle novelist was
generally practiced in the United States
I am sure that most of this mortality
would be reduced
and this is the reason that I have spent
a great deal of time a great deal of
effort and not a little money in
spreading the gospel of the low cervical
cesarean section or lateral drink about
ladies and gentlemen it is now six years
since the picture which you just saw was
published and I am going to tell you
what has happened to the operation
lateral tracheotomy during this time but
first I want to show you those baby boys
will you come in
I believe that she's only do better
mentally and physically than children
delivered from below attention salute
let's save mark
what has happened to the operation
during these six years several
modifications have been suggested and we
have tried it but we have found that the
method reduced saw on the screen and
which was perfected after 40 years of
trial is still the best for example the
transfer further potency
a transfer curvilinear incision is made
above the bladder he tried the operation
ten times and gave it up one severe
hemorrhage from the base of the broad
ligament one dangerous extension of the
womb a big baby price difficulty in
featuring the upper to the lower left
the upper muscular lamellae
has retracted into the fundus of the
uterus and run almost fatal pulmonary
embolism the literature records the fact
that there are more pulmonary embolisms
after the transverse incision done after
the rancher Tiffany we have one embolism
intending transverse incision and we
have only one embolism in the 1,800
other lateral tracheotomies the fridges
are germ ecologist would be very happy
if they could record 1,800 consecutive
laparotomies with only one feminine
embolism this is the median incision if
the baby is large you can extend it up
or down towards the cervix if a terror
occurs it does not go into the basis of
the broad ligament where the big vessels
and the ureter are if the womb should
get infected the dangerous areas the big
veins are far away doctor
these packing oh yes we pack the uterus
routinely but we are now using a Chris
Raven iodine and glycerin on the doll I
wonder if there really is an antiseptic
that does good that we have a better
preparation it is called gurgle movie
regarding post-operative adhesions
we have done second and third lateral
tracheotomy on 335 patients and we found
adhesions to be the exception
whereas after the classic cesarean
section adhesions are the world and they
not seldom cause serious mate
complications fertility life life is not
compromised by the low operation as it
says by the classic
rupture of the uterus in subsequent
pregnancy and really the physical star
has proven its superiority there are
only three cases on record a rupture of
the star during pregnancy and during
labor there are less than 50 cases on
record where as the classic cesarean is
notoriously dangerous in this respect
there are thousands of ruptures to which
discredits doctors Baba Mustafa previa
we're done 120 lateral tracheotomy in
percent of previa without a single death
some doctors claimed that the classic
cesarean section is better in this
complication but we believe just the
opposite we want to make the opening in
the uterus others of death of the
profession where we can attack a
hemorrhage should one occur make the
incision a little bit higher on the
uterus than usual the bleeding is only
marked if the placenta happens to be on
the anterior role we borrow physical
sentence grass for foot and slowly bring
the breach into the opening just the
same as you do Rendon the gray from
below if after the
in the dead of the placenta bleeds you
simply sew it up like this you see it is
very easy to stop the bleeding
you literally the better the placenta
the number of pepper
regarding consensus case we have not
broadened the indications to wrap or it
allowed me to cover the frankly and
sexist case but we have rich tips even
when the bag of others has been ruptured
a long time when several vaginal
examination have been made when labor
has been to learn and when Trust has
been attempted providing there was a
reasonable amount of cleanliness the
peril operation is still the best for
the frankly infected patients that's
although it is sad to have to say it
craniotomy may still be considered in
rare instance local anesthesia local
anesthesia has helped materially to
reduce our maternal mortality it is
better than final in every way and even
the neurologists are telling us are late
diseases resulting from this invasion of
the spinal canal lateral tracheotomy is
the ideal cesarean and experience the
world over has justified all the claims
we have lived for it we remember I told
you that it would cut your mortality in
half well look at this chart
city of Chicago 1934 490 classics yes
five and a half percent laughing a
trickle out of me
five hundred and thirty one to fix them
German classics for a hundred and thirty
eight deaths six and 4/10 mrs. lapping
of tracheotomies thirty five hundred and
fifty four yes three and seven ten
percent
Chicago lying-in Hospital 1914 to 1936
out of sixty thousand deliveries sixty
thousand delivery classics 168 deaths
six percent lateral tracheotomies 815
111 1811 death eighteen from all causes
tuberculosis in France fierce fight
disease etcetera one percent
now ladies and gents a final word
I believe in view of all these facts
that I may in all fairness
ask you this question does a man in
defending the old classic cesarean
section then the lower cervical
operation could be done don't he give
his patients all the benefits of modern
obstetric heart
[Music]